hi I'm Eric singer I'm a dialect coach
so in the technique critique videos
where we talk about accent performances
movies Margot Robbie is really a
fantastic accent performer I don't know
if and have time to go into depth about
this or that aspect of language and
today I want to talk about some
mind-blowing facts about language and
linguistics so let's just talk about the
inventory of speech sounds in a language
English has about forty to forty four
distinct speech sounds depending on the
accent the variety of English and we're
talking about sounds that can make the
difference between one word and another
[Music]
English has an e sound and an S sound
which can change the meaning of a word
beat is different from bit other
languages may not have both of those
sounds in them what is the largest
number of speech sounds that a language
can have turns out it's somewhere
between ninety and a hundred and ten
depending on how you count them a lot of
the languages with the largest sound
inventories turn out to be click
languages because there are lots of ways
that you can combine those clicks let's
have a look
three clicks or C which is pronounced on
the flip side what is the smallest
number of sounds that a language can
function with turns out it's about ten
or eleven the piraha language in the
Amazonian Basin is one of those
languages yeah so there's a huge variety
there in the ways different languages
work and that doesn't mean anything
about a particular language or its
people or the way they think or what
they're able to express language is just
working differently it's a huge variety
next up the great vowel shift
[Music]
so one of the fundamental facts about
language kind of the fundamental fact
about language that we know from
linguistics which is the scientific
study of language is that it changes one
period of really interesting fast sound
change in the history of English is
something called the great vowel shift
starting around 1400 a word that we know
is named around 1400 used to be nama and
then that the middle changed to AH so we
had Nam then it was an a so we had men
then it was a long a so we had name and
then finally it came to the diphthong
that most varieties of English have now
something like name so it was a long
distance to travel another example would
be the vowel sound and a word like house
started off as ooh so it was a hoose Val
santanu word like time started off as an
e so it was team and over time it became
to be time and that was a period of
really rapid and complete change but
it's an example of the kind of thing
that's happening all the time
so why does this happen we don't know
really for no reason at all again if
there's something we know from the
scientific study of language the field
of linguistics
it's that language change is essentially
arbitrary moving on the American are
sound I've talked about that in some
performances and some of the technique
critique videos as being a really hard
or American English has a really weird R
sound this thing that you do when you
bunch up your tongue this is a really
weird sound it barely exists in any
other language on earth really mastering
this kind of our sound and being able to
slot it fluidly into a flow of speech is
one of the hardest things for an actor
to learn when they're learning American
English in fact native speakers of
American English find it really hard to
it's one of the very last sounds that a
child learns and kind of masters so why
is it so hard it turns out it's really
complicated
it's a weird set of things we're doing
with our tongue when we make that sound
mostly the weirdest thing is that the
sides of the tongue are sort of coming
out
you can imagine kind of if I'm a tongue
and I'm raising my shoulders the size of
those tongue will come up and they'll
make contact with the upper teeth the
molars and the bicuspids on either side
and you can have a really strong version
of that where they come all the way up
inside and even press out against the
sides of the upper teeth you can get a
sense of this if we look at an MRI scan
of a person pronouncing this kind of
molar are let's have a look real in
addition to that the root of the tongue
is often pulling back in and you can
even get a little groove in the back of
the tongue so all of those things going
on it's a really complex articulation
hard to get right if you're a kid hard
to get right if it's not your native
language moving on there's this accent
that often gets called transatlantic or
mid-atlantic as though somebody were
maybe born on an island halfway between
the US and England you can hear a great
example of this accent here build these
foams out at the desk over there and
bring them to me there's another great
one here you mind if I ask you a
personal question what are the things
that's really interesting about it is
it's essentially a made-up accent it's
synthetic it's not a way that anybody
talks natively I think so this is an
accent that was essentially invented in
its earliest form by one guy an
Australian named William Tilley who at
the end of the 19th century thought that
there might be something to be gained by
everybody who spoke English speaking
exactly the same way so he devised this
accent that was sort of the best accent
of English it was correct speech and he
wanted everybody everywhere to speak
this it became a thing in the United
States where he was teaching I was
taught in the New York City Public
Schools and it became the accent of
stage and screen and so actors were
taught to speak this way that this was
correct speech so the early version of a
dialect coach I was usually called an
elocution teacher was really different
essentially because they were teaching
actors to speak correctly not teaching
actors how to speak like
the character that they were playing so
this mid-atlantic
accent this perfect correct speech
that's this synthetic created accent I
wouldn't love to put the world and all
the men he'll so that's why we hear that
in the old movies all the time so this
has been a few kind of cool things about
language things I think are cool thanks
for listening
[Music]